nor does the eminent so-called pure
mathematics set time as time over
against space as the second material for
its consideration applied mathematics
does indeed deal with time as well as
with motion and other concrete things
but the synthetic propositions that is
propositions regarding relationships
determined by their notion it takes from
experience and applies its formula only
on those presuppositions the fact that
the so called proofs of propositions
such as those regarding the equilibrium
of a lever or the relation of space and
time and the motion of falling and so
forth are often given an except that as
proofs itself only proves how great is
the need of proof for cognition seeing
that we're nothing better is to be had
cognition values even the hollow
semblance of it and obtains from it some
measure of its satisfaction a critique
of these proofs would be as noteworthy
as it would be instructive partly in
order to strip mathematics of these fine
feathers partly in order to point out
its limitations and thus show the
necessity for a different kind of
knowledge as for time which it is to be
presumed what constitute as the
counterpart of space the material of the
other part of pure mathematics it is the
it is the existent notion itself the
principle of magnitude of difference not
determined by the notion and the
principle of equality of abstract
lifeless unity cannot cope with the
sheer unrest of life in its absolute
distinction
it is therefore only in a paralyzed form
that is as a numerical unit that this
negativity becomes the second material
mathematical cognition which as an
external activity reduces what is self
moving to mere material so as to possess
in it an indifferent external lifeless
concept
lifeless content
in section 46 Hegel is continuing this
criticism of what he calls mathematical
cognition there Kenan that he began
several passages ago yeah he's going to
introduce a new question here namely
that of time so let's review for just a
moment what do we mean by mathematical
cognition
he doesn't just mean mathematics as a
discipline or as a subject matter
dealing with numbers dealing with
quantity what he means is the extension
of mathematics into practically
everything the use of it as not just a
model but also a means as a medium for
making sense out of all reality and this
was actually something that was you know
a real going concern in the early modern
and even late modern era that he's sort
of at the cusp of we can speak of the
mathematize ation not only of nature but
also this conception that was running
through a lot of people's ideas that
that went on all the way to the low
justice project in the 20th century that
mathematics could really be the basis
for making sense out of everything
mathematics understand a very broad
conception of it and why does he will
consider this to be problematic here
he's going to discuss it in terms of
pure mathematics and applied mathematics
so for those who aren't quite familiar
with that that distinction it's probably
good to dwell on it a little bit so when
we're talking about pure mathematics
we're talking about engaging in
mathematics you could say for its own
sake without considering how it can
apply to particular experiences
particular problems particular things
that were we're interested in we're
looking at the relations numbers bear to
each other and all the operations that
we can perform on them and everything
that can be you know reduced to or
expressed in terms of number we're
looking at that for its own sake perhaps
we know with an eye to applying it later
in order to make sense of it on its own
terms
now when we're talking about applied
mathematics what we're talking about is
something that's more experiential it
does in fact have a a sort of you know
universal schematic quality to it as
well a lever as a lever is a lever and
we can have a general idea of a lever
but we make sense out of levers by
reference to actual lived experience to
some degree so Hegel is going to say how
do these two ways of doing mathematics
how do they understand this very
important metaphysical what do we want
to call it not even a concept this this
very important metaphysical reality
something that we have to take into
account that we call time and he says
so-called pure mathematics does not set
time as time over again space is a
second material for its consideration
what does he mean by that well if you
think back to your mathematics whether
you had it in high school or college or
you know if you're really advanced you
did some of this in middle school and
you think in terms of dimensions the
Cartesian coordinates right and think of
it in two dimensions you can represent a
plane and that could be representing
spaciality you can come up with
equations that describe whatever figure
that you want to live nets are recording
this up but any any figure you can think
of you can come up with some sort of
mathematical formula however complex
that would express it what about
three-dimensional things yes we can
there's a matter of fact that's why we
can do things like like 3d printing
which is really you know large you
extend an extension of what's been going
on in factories with modeling and design
for quite some time
now what about if we had a fourth
dimension walk'n times people will talk
about time as being the fourth dimension
and the reason why this whole idea of
time is being the fourth dimension
about is because if you represent time
as a variable like the variables in
space then you can chart things out not
in a way that we can actually you know
look at in in graphic terms we can do
sort of approximations of that kind of
thing
but we can conceptualize it in terms of
another dimension you know you can have
X Y Z and then T and you can say that
what's happening in terms of X Y Z is
dependent on where things are at time T
time to use you know one pick whatever
notation you like if you do that
Hegel's saying you're really not
treating time is something distinct by
itself you're just treating it as yet
another type of variable which is like
the variables of spaciality and you can
do this this works as a matter of fact
it has a lot of applications in real
life but are you adequately grasping
time by doing so Hegel would say no what
about if we turn to applied mathematics
if we're if we're looking at the world
of experience where you know the
terminology that he's using here he's
saying you know everything that we look
at as being synthetic propositions these
are propositions regarding relationships
determined by their notion these are
taken from experience these are not when
you say that something is a synthetic
proposition he's using this this
conscient terminology it means that
things are being brought together
you can't derive what it is that the
proposition is saying just by looking at
the parts of in saying all haha there we
go there has to be some sort of process
of inference going on Kant thought that
you could have synthetic propositions
off priori where you don't have to have
some sort of experience involved that's
not really that big of an issue here
Hegel's point is everything that we're
calling synthetic everything
that we're calling you know universal
truths in terms of mathematics in terms
of motion experience you know mechanics
he uses the example of the lever all
that is actually derived from our
experience or the experience of other
people that we have you know accumulated
over time and gradually turned into a
discipline or a set of disciplines
you know mechanics is really applied
mathematics Descartes actually has this
depiction of a tree that mathematics is
the root of and then metaphysics and
mechanics is one portion of it
medicine and morals were the other two
branches coming off of it so he says the
fact that the so called proofs of
propositions such as those regarding the
equilibrium of the lever of the relation
of space and time and the motion of
falling or given an accepted of proofs
only proves how great the need of proof
for cognition seeing that we're nothing
better is to be at cognition of values
even the hollow semblance of it his
point there is not to say that it's all
you know fabricated or forget all of it
he's not introducing a kind of
skepticism there he's saying look the
things that you're actually calling
proofs are not proofs in any sort of
real sense which demonstrate the
necessity of the phenomena that were
we're looking at so we're not gonna get
our heads around time as philosophers as
you know scientists in the visum shop
sense of science those who are trying to
understand reality as meta physicians
we're not going to get ahead around time
by thinking of in terms of mathematics
here I'd like to bring up a little bit
of a digression as well why would there
be this sense that we ought to think of
time in terms of mathematics is it just
that we're attracted to math well you
know this this ideas along pedigree goes
all the way back to Aristotle who said
that time is the number of change
or quantity or however you want to to
parse it out of Kinesis can I say
actually in the Greek and sometimes this
is talked about in terms of motion but
he's really talking about the broader
category of change
he also says a few other things about
time that I'll get to in a moment that
that tie-in more closely to what Hegel
is expressing here
well let's fast forward now to somebody
else who's very important in the
understanding of the relationship of
time to number and that's Augustine
Augustine says that strictly speaking at
least from our perspective the presence
is all that there is it's this tiny
little slice and now this presents go on
the past doesn't exist the future
doesn't yet exist so where does all this
stuff come from how do we measure
something that doesn't actually exist
ie time well we measure it because we
actually have a capacity for keeping
track of it and we do so through a kind
of numbering for example if we're
talking he uses the examples of long and
short syllables because because Latin
poetry actually was not based on rhyme
and rhymes were used to in English it
was instead based on mirror and metre
depends on long and short syllables
depends on the vowels there's a whole
long story there that I don't need to go
into suffice it to say what Augustine
was pointing out is that in our minds we
actually compare experiences against
each other and we can say this
experience is twice as long that's that
one now is it time itself that's
dictating that or is it are imposing a
structure on things that's doing so
that's the key question there of course
with Augustine there's God in the
picture and so there's the divine mind
and that that complicates things as well
fast forward now to to cut who is you
know looking at these matters after
having had you know some some great
mathematicians themselves trying to make
sense of these things like Newton like
Leibniz cog will treat time
as something that is not out there
existing in itself but actually
something that is a form of our
intuition of things that we actually
have to put our experiences into time
and space as well in order for them to
be able to make sense to us in order for
there to be sequence and so again time
and number are intimately connected in
the minds of many of these people who
are who are treating metaphysics so
Hegel's going to depart from them and
he's going to ask you know what is time
in order to broach this question we
really need to get away from mathematics
and engage in metaphysics and a Galleon
metaphysics is phenomenology it is
attentive to what's going on in
consciousness how do things actually
appear to us so he says as for time
which it is to be presumed would
constitute as a counterpart of space the
material of the other part of pure
mathematics time is the existent notion
itself that's a strange thing to say
because he's not treating time merely as
a medium in which other things can occur
or be oriented towards each other he's
saying that time itself is the existent
notion or concept he says the principle
of magnitude difference not determined
by the notion of the principle of
equality cannot cope with and here he
brings up another key term the sheer
restlessness of life and its absolute
distinction now he's not just talking
about being a lie he's talking about
life in a metaphysical sense life as
that which actually pervades things life
is itself in motion but it's not just
like a sickle cyclical circular motion
it's not you know random there is
purposiveness to it there is development
that takes place also decline from time
to time
but what's going on is what he's calling
the development of the notion and it's
happening through four human beings who
are the ones matter of course history
we've gotten very far away when we talk
about mathematics we've gotten very far
away from mathematics in talking about
history so it says mathematics and any
sort of approach that's going to found
itself basically on mathematics cannot
actually take account of what's really
going on with time this doesn't mean
that it can't grasp certainly aspects of
time doesn't mean that you know in
treating it as a quantifiable dimension
like space like the three dimensions of
space that it's doing something wrong
it's just that that's not an adequate
way to understand reality as it develops
for human beings who have meanings
there's a few other things that that
really ought to be said at this point
about this he's saying what happens when
we try to mathematize this what we're
actually trying to grasp lip slips
through our fingers he says negativity
becomes the second material of
mathematical cognition which is external
activity remember we saw that
mathematics doesn't really reveal the
insides of things
it's a schema that gets superimposed on
them it reduces what itself moving to
mirror material so as to possess it in
an indifferent external lifeless content
this is the real danger of mathematize
and things it can actually work and when
it does work it doesn't grasp what its
leaving out and you can't point out to
the not that necessarily the
mathematician because mathematicians are
actually quite aware of this but to the
person who's bedazzled by mathematics as
a medium for doing this sort of stuff
you can't get them to see that something
has been left out because when they you
know when they say to you in good faith
well show me what's been left out
they're gonna
be placed in terms of mathematics I
mentioned that I was going to bring up
one other point about Aristotle
Aristotle in the physics where he's
saying that that time is the number of
motion with respect to before and after
she also says something else that's very
important which is more in line with
what Hegel is saying here about time and
about number Aristotle says that time is
that in which
potentiality and actuality really work
themselves out in relation to each other
that's part of what Hegel is trying to
get at in talking in terms here of life
of motion self movement he's talking
about the development not from pure
possibility not from any sort of you
know mathematical seed that would have
to play itself out in a certain way
algorithmically or you know iteratively
but rather he's talking about how
potentiality in an Aristotelian sense
develops itself into actuality for us
human beings that involves in purpose of
activity and choice that's really what
history is in large part composed of
it's a product of all of that likewise
so is build on our culture
philosophy on the other hand he has to
do not with uh nacelle determinations
but with a determination insofar as it
is essential its element and content is
not the abstract or not actual but the
actual that which posits itself and is
alive within itself existence within its
own notion it is the process which
baguettes and traverses its own moments
and this whole movement constitutes what
is positive in it and its truth this
truth therefore includes the negative
also what would be called the false if
it could be regarded as something from
which one might abstract the Evanescence
itself must on the contrary be regarded
as essential not as something fixed cut
off from the true and left lying who
knows where outside of it any more than
the truths to be regarded as something
on the other side positive in dead
appearance is the arising and passing
away that does not itself arise and pass
away but is in itself that is subsist
intrinsically and constitutes the
actuality and the movement of the life
of truth the true is thus the
bacchanalian revel in which no member is
not drunk
yet because each member collapses as
soon as he drops out the revel is just
as much transparent and simple repose
judged in the court of this movement the
simple shapes of spirit do not persist
any more than determinate thoughts do
but there is much positive and necessary
moments as they are negative and
evanescent in the whole of the movements
seen as a state of repose what
distinguishes itself therein and gives
itself particular existence is preserved
as something that recollects itself
whose existence is self-knowledge and
whose self-knowledge is just as
immediately existence
close to the end of Hegel's criticisms
of mathematical cognition we have this
interesting section number 47 where he's
not going to talk about mathematics at
all but he is going to talk about
bacchanalian travels in which no member
is drunk yet because each member
collapses as soon as he drops out the
rebel is just as much transparent and
simple repose so when you think about
bacchanalian travels which is where we
want to get to in this this this chapter
and indeed through the phenomenology you
want to think of a big party that you've
been to where people are actually moving
around dancing singing you might think
of a festival rather than a party
because I think for many of us parties
are a little bit more sedate than that
in any case a bacchanalian revel what
the way that he's picturing it here a
bacchanalian revel would be one in which
everybody would be drunk because Bacchus
is in fact the god of wine he's Dionysus
and Greek he's Bacchus and in Latin but
now imagine one where there's a kind of
equilibrium and repose to the entirety
of the party of the entirety of the
revel even though every single part
itself is in fact off-kilter off-balance
drunk and there you've got an image of
the entire development of the shapes of
consciousness as they're detailed here
in Hegel's phenomenology this is an
image that one should not lose sight of
if one wants to understand what's going
on in Hegel's discussions there's always
going to be a loss of equity briam
that's part of what drives the dialectic
forward but understood as a whole we can
reach a point where we as the sort of
privileged observers and Hegel can see
that you know this this whole thing is
like a calm clean progression so it's
like a mirror image a distorted mirror
image to some degree of what's going on
in here
in any case he starts out saying
philosophy is concerned with what with
what is essential and that means that
it's going to be concerned with what is
actual what is very good what is able to
do something to exert itself to show
itself to appear on the stage he is
going to talk about appearance in just a
moment so he poses this dilemma how
should we understand what is actually
essential how should we make sense out
of this and there are different ways in
which one can do this one classical way
of doing this in philosophy and you
still see a lot of people doing this
today is then we're going to concentrate
on what can be the case in every time
irregardless of circumstances that's
where we need to really put our focus we
need to abstract away from the concrete
we need to abstract away from experience
or we need to at least say all of our
experiences in this respect are going to
be equal and you know that's a way of
doing philosophy that a lot of people
have have espoused over time the problem
is when you do that what is abstract
will also be something that's not actual
so is what's most important is what's
most real is what we really need to
grasp to work our you know our rear ends
off and our brains to comprehend is it
something that's not actual is it
something that's purely ideal as an
existing solely for the mind or perhaps
is a cultural artifact or something like
that or is what's essential in some
respect what becomes actual what has to
be brought from
mere abstraction or potentiality to the
state of actualities to actually
existing in concrete shapes in spaces in
times in cultures here there in this
person and in differentiated ways ways
that are somewhat again walk kilter he
uses this term self positing there
another term that he uses is that which
is alive within itself existence in its
own notion and here he's not just
talking about individual existences he's
talking about important things that come
on the scene in time in history in
culture perhaps recurringly more often
than not but through persons through
subjects through actually existing
concrete human beings and the question
here is should we be paying attention to
the eternal which is where you know a
lot of philosophy has been looking for
an Hegel has no problem with actually
using this word evanescent meaning that
which it just sort of rises to the
surface and exists for a moment and that
is go on you know what does evanescent
is you know for example mayflies that
are born for a day mate and die but
mayflies as a species continue that's
part of the point here and so what we
need to do is a little bit of a ratio so
we can see the bigger point that he's
actually trying to make by introducing
this distinction or this dilemma that we
have to grapple with so he's got this
this famous passage talking about the
the bacchanalian revel in which no
member is is not drunk and was he
talking about there he's talking about
let's think about this we've got a party
here and we've got people in the party
and what happens at parties
people get drunk they pass out they
dance for a while and then they're no
longer around the scene they're off the
scene right and then somebody else comes
in to take their place and in this way
the party can continue and continuing
can continue and sooner or later all of
the original party members have actually
left perhaps some are cast out at
bedrooms under coats some hooked up with
each other some you know drove off and
threw up in the bushes somewhere and
others are coming in to replace them I
don't need to draw a million different
X's here you get the idea what I'm what
I'm after
Hegel's saying that there's this
continual process now let's think of
this not in terms of a party and people
getting drunk but in terms of truth
in terms of the truth of appearance the
truth of the evanescent he says because
each member collapsed as soon as he
drops out the rebel is just as much
transparent and simpler post judged in
the court of this movement the simple
shapes of spirits so now think of each
of these as being a simple shape of
spirit or Geist consciousness through
history and I'm erasing this in part
because we want to think of these as
sort of on these sort of lines they're
existing then they cease to exist
they're succeeding each other
perhaps we should actually put you know
all sorts of different things why Zoe's
you know Greek letters numerals the
point is there is a process
and considered from the point of view of
anyone given part of the process it's
completely incomplete it's inadequate
what happens just with this stage is
something comes on the scene appears
develops itself is revealed as
inadequate you know the negativity of it
arises and then it's superseded by
something else and this may be as Hegel
says sublated that is you know alcohol
been that taken up into in its essential
moments into the next stage but it's
it's done remember we have this metaphor
earlier on about the flower of the bud
you know the seeds all of that sort of
stuff that's the same sort of process so
considered from the point of view just
of one individual state the single
shapes of spirit do not persist any more
than determinate thoughts do so imagine
think about your own thoughts and how
ephemeral those are you're thinking
about one thing now you're thinking
about another thing now you're probably
thinking about Hegel and in five minutes
you're gonna think about should I have a
sandwich the shapes of consciousness
considered in history are as ephemeral
as that but he says they are as much
positive and necessary movements as they
are negative and evanescent in the whole
of movement in the entirety of the
process considered in a state of repose
what distinguishes itself therein gives
itself particular existence is preserved
as something which distinguishes itself
within give itself particular existence
is preserved as something that
recollects itself that remembers this
entire process and this is where handled
himself would say that he is as he's
writing this book this is where we
ourselves as we're following along
that's the position that we really
occupy all of this has happened already
and we're following it out
watching the appearances we're seeing
how potentiality works itself into
actuality and then reveals itself is
having yet more potentiality that hasn't
been realized and that works itself out
more and what's here in the past starts
to die off and give rise to something
else and new changes occur all of it is
able to be grasped from the vantage
point of these things having occurred so
he says something that Recoleta
recollects itself whose existence is
self-knowledge and whose self-knowledge
is just as immediately existence what's
important to point out here with respect
to that passage are two things one is
that this is going to be a more
theoretical perspective than the active
perspectives that are going on through
the development of history the other
thing is this is very important this
vantage point he has to be one where we
ourselves grasp that we are at this
point we are the ones who have the
responsibility of looking back at all
the developments of history seeing what
occurred going through them as much as
we can an imagination of perhaps emotion
or appreciation and then conceptualizing
it
we cannot be as you might say pure
passive consumers something like the
phenomenology a consumer attitude
towards this of just and just show me
this stuff just entertain me just give
me the data we've already seen that
Hegel says look you're not going to get
anything out of this book if that's the
attitude that you take towards it you
have to to some degree go along for the
ride